>> AMERICA MUST NEVER AGAIN BE
HELL HOSTAGE TO FOREIGN
SUPPLIERS OF ENERGY AS WE WERE
UNDER THE OBAMA-BIDEN -- SLEEPY
JOE -- GROUP.
SLEEPY JOE.
HE WAS SOMEPLACE IN IOWA TODAY.
HE SAID MY NAME SO MANY TIMES,
PEOPLE COULDN'T STAND IT
ANYMORE.
NO, DON'T KEEP SAYING IT.
SLEEPY GUY.
>> Sean: I'M TELLING YOU, JOE
BIDEN IS NOT GOING TO HANDLE
WHAT IS COMING HIS WAY.
THE PRESIDENT IN IOWA TODAY
GOING AFTER JOE BIDEN'S RECORD
WHICH IS ATROCIOUS ALONG WITH
BARACK OBAMA.
HERE WITH REACTION TO THIS AND
MORE, SENATE JUDICIALRY
CHAIRMAN -- HE CRACKS ME UP --
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS WITH US.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT READY FOR THIS
FIGHT.
>> GOING TO BE FUN.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
LETTER YESTERDAY.
THE NEW DEVELOPMENTS BY JUDICIAL
WATCH TONIGHT, THE SERIOUSNESS
OF WHICH THIS HAS TAKEN OVER
HERE.
>> RIGHT.
SO HOROWITZ WILL BE COMING OUT
SOON, I HOPE, WITH HIS INTERNAL
REVIEW OF THE FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION, WHETHER OR NOT THE
COURT WAS DEFRAUDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI.
DURHAM IS GOING TO LOOK AT ALL
THINGS CRIMINAL.
HE'S ON THE CASE.
THE COLLUSION NARRATIVE HAS DIED
WITH THE MUELLER REPORT.
THE CORRUPTION NARRATIVE IS
GROWING BY EVERY DAY WHEN YOU
FIND MORE E-MAILS LIKE YOU HAD
TONIGHT.
>> Sean: I REFER TO YOUR
QUESTIONING OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ABOUT MUELLER, ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY,
ABOUT FISA ABUSE, THE ORIGINS --
HE GAVE YOU ALL THE ANSWERS.
NOW IT APPEARS HE'S IMPLEMENTING
WHAT SEEMS TO BE AN EXHAUSTIVE
TOP TO BOTTOM INVESTIGATION INTO
ALL THINGS SERIOUS.
DO YOU BELIEVE WHEN HE TALKS
ABOUT INTELLIGENCE, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THAT LETTER
THAT HE IS REFERRING TO THE
POSSIBILITY OF OUTSOURCED
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING TO
CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAW?
>> MAYBE SO.
MAYBE GETTING FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS TO DO THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO, WHICH EVERY AMERICAN
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THE FISA COURT, WHICH IS A
SECRET COURT, WAS LIED TO ABOUT
THE SOURCE OF INFORMATION TO USE
TO GATHER A WARRANT.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE WORRIED
WHETHER OR NOT OUR GOVERNMENT
TRIED TO GET A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT TO DO.
HE'S ON THE CASE.
>> Sean: BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW
NOW, CLOSED DOOR TESTIMONY OF
BRUCE OHR, HE WARNED EVERYBODY,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S MOTIVES.
IT'S NOT VERIFIED.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT MEETING,
THE ONE KATHLEEN HAD TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE FIRST FISA
APPLICATION.
STAUNCH WARNING.
DON'T TRUST THIS GUY.
HE'S HAS A POLITICAL AGENDA.
COMEY SIGNED THE FIRST FISA
APPLICATION.
NOW WE NOW KNOW IT'S AN
UNVERIFIABLE DOCUMENT AND ITS
OWN AUTHOR DOES NOT STAND NEXT
TO IT.
HOW IS THAT NOT A PREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON THE FISA COURT, NOT
JUST TO TAKE AWAY THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES OF CARTER PAGE BUT A
BACK DOOR INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN PRESIDENCY?
>> IF THIS WAS ABOUT REPUBLICANS
DOING WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED TO
A DEMOCRAT, IT WOULD BE FRONT
PAGE NEWS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THE ONLY PLACE YOU CAN FIND IT
ON YOUR SHOW AND A FEW OTHER
SHOWS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE GET AROUND
THE FACT THAT COMEY TELLS THE
PRESIDENT IN JANUARY 2017 HERE'S
THE DOSSIER.
>> Sean: UNVERIFIED.
>> UNVERIFIED.
AND THAT SAME DOCUMENT WAS THE
REASON A WARRANT WAS ISSUED FOUR
TIMES AND UNDER OATH COMEY TELLS
THE FISA COURT IT'S RELIABLE
ENOUGH TO GET A WARRANT.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU SQUARE
THAT CIRCLE, BUT THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE HOROWITZ AND THAT'S WHAT MY
COMMITTEE WILL BE LOOKING AT.
>> Sean: SENATOR, IS THERE NOT
AT THIS POINT INCONTROVERTIBLE
EVIDENCE?
IF IT'S UNVERIFIABLE AND THE
BULK OF THE DOSSIER AND IT'S IN
THE GRASSLEY GRAHAM MEMO AND THE
BULK OF INFORMATION THAT THAT IS
A PREMEDITATED FRAUD AGAINST THE
COURT, HOW IS IT ANYTHING ELSE?
GIVE ME ANY POSSIBLE THEORY.
>> ALL I CAN TELL YOU FOR SURE,
WE KNOW STEELE WENT TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT TRYING TO GET THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO RELEASE THE
DOSSIER BEFORE THE ELECTION
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TRUMP TO
LOSE AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT
TOLD THE FBI ABOUT THE ENCOUNTER
BEFORE THE WARRANT.
IN AUGUST AS YOU SAID BEFORE,
OHR TELLS THE FBI AND DOJ, WATCH
STEELE, HE'S OUT TO GET TRUMP.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU EXPLAIN
THIS STUFF OTHER THAN IT'S A
FRAUD ON THE COURT, A POLITICAL
AGENDA BY STEELE.
>> Sean: WHAT IF I DID THIS?
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO ME?
>> YOU WOULDN'T HAVE A SHOW.
>> Sean: WOULD I BE LIVING IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE?
>> I WOULD NOT BE PLAYING GOLF
WITH YOU.
>> Sean: EVER AGAIN.
>> EVER AGAIN.
>> Sean: NOW MY BACK IS BETTER.
>> GOOD.
WE'LL DO IT AGAIN.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
LET ME ASK YOU ON YOUR END
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE DURHAM,
HOROWITZ.
WE'VE GOT JOHN HOOVER.
WE HAVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
DURHAM AND YOUR COMMITTEE.
HOW DEEP AND HOW FAR WILL YOU GO
BACK?
TO ME, IF WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
AND APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS, IT
HAS TO BE IN THE BEGINNING.
>> YOU HAVE TO FIND OUT HOW THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION BEGAN AND
HOW IT ENDED --
>> Sean: YOU THINK IT WAS
RIGGED?
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO
ME THAT IF YOU WANT HER TO WIN,
YOU CAN'T INDICT HERE.
THE MAIN REASON SHE WASN'T
CHARGED WITH A CRIME IS BECAUSE
PEOPLE INVESTIGATING HER WANTED
TRUMP TO LOSE AND HER TO WIN.
YEAH.
>> Sean: 100 MILLION TO ZERO.
>> THAT'S A LOT.
>> Sean: AND AREN'T THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE VOTING FOR DONALD
TRUMP SMELLY WALMART SHOPPERS
LIKE ME?
>> THE SAME PEOPLE DID THE
CLINTON E-MAIL INVESTIGATION DID
THE COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AND GOT THE
WARRANT.
THEY'RE ALL THE SAME PEOPLE.
>> Sean: AMAZING.